all right instead of making a
last-minute trip to the store to grab a
valentine's day card this year
show them you care with something
homemade kayla cooper is a craft expert
from joann's stores to show
us how hi kayla i am terrible at crafts
help me out here
um basically the only supplies you're
going to need today are
some already pre-made cards in a package
like this
5x7 and we also have some stickers
little foam stickers and the thing i
love about this is that
no glue so the kids can get involved and
there's no mess
i love this i'm already starting so i've
got my card
and i've got tons of stickers we've got
everything under the rainbow here
pinks and blues and sparkles and stuff
so you just take the card and just get
these on here and not
you don't have to worry about any of the
mess absolutely
and like i said you know you just you
can re arrange them on your card however
you like just kind of
place them and because they're stickers
you can kind of just place them on there
as
any kind of way you want play around
with it and
that way you can rearrange as you see
fit
i love this idea and this is something
that you can do with the kids too
you can you can surprise the one you
love or
you can even make these for their
classroom if they're in school and
they're doing valentine's day
absolutely and especially with the kids
being in class it's a great way if
they're learning patterns in school
to kind of incorporate a hands-on
activity that brings the classroom
to life in their very own hands now
after you have your card made i assume
you got to write
something sweet do you have any like
cute little ideas on what we can write
to our valentines
absolutely um i know that you know i
addressed a lot of them to my
grandparents i know a lot of us haven't
had a chance to be with our grandparents
lately so maybe the grandkids could
write something really special and sweet
to them
or any other loved one really um so
you know be mine all those other fun
little valentines
um little sayings and i have a couple
examples here
so we made some flowers um with the
heart
we also did a little balloon bouquet
that's another good idea
um and then if you do want we also do
uh the little wood pieces and you can
decorate those and paint them to
personalize them if you want to take it
up a notch
i love it i i made one tell me if it
gets your seal of approval here
it's kind of plain but on the inside i
made it for ted
who is here at the station and it says
ted i made a
math equation two sweet two b forgotten
does that get the seal of approval
that's perfect you did a phenomenal job
i love it
awesome thank you so much caleb we'll
send it over to you jc
i'm stealing that and using it for my
wife all right if you're